hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we were back at the 1921
World Chess Championship match between
josé raúl capablanca and Emmanuel Lasker
this is a game six after four games well
for very fighting games that ended in
the draw capablanca was finally able to
win Game five I was a really intense
game and if you've been with us from the
beginning you know that Alaska played a
brilliant game he sacrificed the
exchange he tried to make it happen and
then in the end just blundered you know
it was this move draws this mooses last
which was the only move that loses and a
couple of guys now up one point in the
match so here last group with the white
pieces in game 6 can't he equalized the
match and well just try and hold on well
to to the title so to say so last but
with the white pieces opens would be
four and it's very interesting a lot
Alaska will play the exact same line
that a couple wonka played against him
in Game three of this match which we've
covered with E 5 Knight to f3 ignites
the c6 and Bishop to b5 rule opus is on
the board and Knight to f6 capablanca
goes for the Berlin defense with castles
by Lasker b6 and now d4 so like I said
up until move I don't know it's a move
well 13 the game follows game 3 of the
match you know move by move Bishop to d7
by Capablanca Knights the c3 and now
Bishop to e7 we have looked to e1 now
comes he captures on d4 with night cap
for Sun before end couple Blanca castles
Alaska grabs on c6 with V captures on c6
and now Bishop to g5 today Queen to f3
is the main move in this position but
Bishop g5 also can be played with rook
to e8 and now Queen to d3
so just for comparison this line has
continued to you know has been played
after this match for a very long time
for example in 1945 in most of
championship David Brownstein has had
this position against the better
romanovski and romanovski continued with
Knight to g4 offered the trade of the
dark square bishop this way David
Bronstein was able to win this game but
here Lasker continues with h6 with
Bishop to 8
or and now night 2h7 Capablanca offers
to the exchange this way pretty much the
exact same way Alaska did it in Game
three and if you remember we mentioned a
couple blanca says that capturing is the
main line but he feels that worship the
g3 is stronger but for the moment he
decided not to play here alaska also
captures on a seven with rook captures
only seven and here in game 3 kappa
blanka played rookie three followed well
with the idea of rook to g3 where he
wanted to create an attack against the
black king but last Peugeot's queen to
c4 and this is now a new move up until
you know Dan then yeah but it was never
played again after this game last versus
capablanca so it's a very unique move
and a very unique line so the the idea
has just captured opponent c6 and couple
Blanca defends it with a queen - eh now
the c6 point is defended and also put
more pressure on the e4 pawn perhaps
after the night you know jumps to g5
we've looked at eetu Laster now is ready
to double rooks and the e-file come
Bellanca says the rook that III also
could have been considered you know just
in case you want to switch it over to
attack mode but okay Alaska has other
plans we have rook to e2 and now rook to
b8 by Capablanca and just a nice
developing Rookwood a threat so last for
defensive with b3 and now c5 cover
Bangkok is denied back also perhaps make
some room for the bishop if possible
with Knight back to f3 and now
Capablanca says that Knight to g5 would
probably have been better here but here
he played Bishop to b5 and he says he's
not all that satisfied with the end game
that that he got so Knight captures with
Queen captures on b5 Queen captures rook
captures and now the Lasker starts
bringing the King into the game King f1
with Knight to g5 finally and Lasker
avoids the trade and also defends his
efore pawn so Knights the d2 and now
Knights the e6 and here Capablanca says
that this was a very important maneuver
with the night getting it over here and
it was one of the reasons that he
decided to trade Queens in the way that
he did because now he wants the force
last pair to play c3 without last for
playing c3 it would be a very hard
capablanca to deal any damage sure
because here you can see that the beep
on and the night are controlling the c-4
square so if Lasker is unable to push c4
and if he's unable to break the Queen
said with the a pawn then cover Blanca
will have a very hard game so he wants
Laster to play C 3 because at some point
Capablanca will push a 5 and if last
pair pushes a 4 which he probably will
then the b3 pawn will have to be
defended by a piece not by a pawn and
this will allow capablanca you know the
Stifel last course activity so this is
the plan and here last Pro of course
doesn't want to allow Knights to d4 so
he plays C 3 so this part of capo
Blancas plan was achieved with f6 by
capablanca and now Knight to c4 a great
square for the knight with nice to f4
now attacking the rook rook to e3 and
now Knight back sorry Knight back to g6
with Knight back to D 2 and now rook
back to b8 my kappa blanka the rook
cannot come over to the e-file if needed
with g3 taking care of these squares so
coupling cousin I cannot cannot jump
over there and finally a 5 by Capablanca
and this is what Capablanca meant if
he's able to push a 4 and create some
sort of a breakthrough on the Queen side
it will be very good for him
but now as Alaska pushes a 4 and
prevents a for backup Blanca himself the
b3 pawn has to be protected by a piece
instead of by point if this phone was on
c2 the position would be much better for
Lasker so here a couple Lanka says he's
very happy about about the position that
he got nice to e5 okay you push g3 now
you create some other weaknesses with f4
pushing the knife further back and now
Knight to d7
with King to e2 by Lasker and now Knight
to d6
we have King to d3 and now c6 at some
point if Alaska is ready to create a
breakthrough with E 5 Capablanca can
always capture with the F pawn and then
push push the the D pawn forward we have
rook 81 now Alaska doubles on the e-file
and now King to f7 and here if you play
e5 like we mentioned cava Blanca was
ready to capture with the F
on F characters in d5 and he says that
he likes his position well last we could
continue East six for example with check
King f6 rook f1 check King g6 now and
well it's just just a very nice position
for for both white and black but coupled
man can always play something like King
h7 kingi 8 and bring the rook over to f8
and well it's hard to say if the e6 pawn
is a strength or a weakness in this
position so last pair agrees with a
couple Blancas assessment he goes night
the c-4 offers a trade of nights and
capablanca decides well it's time for
this night to go we have night captures
King captures and now just rook to e6
preparing to meet a 5-wood with a nice
capture and then d5 check because the
king is the only now one guarding the b3
pawn and here after some consideration
Alaska decides for a 5 it's hard to say
if anything would be better it's a
pretty pretty difficult position
so last predict push a 5 with F captures
F captures and now d5 with check so
giving up in the c5 pawn with King
cappers on c5 now you see why rook the
e6 was so important to keep an eye on
the c6 pawn and now Capablanca captures
on b3 and here what do you play here now
Capablanca well the material on the
board is equal but you can see that the
both players have well cover Blanca has
three pawn islands last but has 4.1 so
in this regard couple Blancas position
should be better and now he feels that
Alaska is the one that will have to work
for a draw here last pair pushes c4 here
now offers the rook trade we have D
captures in c4 and now look the e4 the
only move that actually works
we have pawn to c3 and now rook the c-4
preparing to play something like well
rook to e3 and then capture the passed
pawn with h5
by Capablanca and now rook to e3 with
rook to be two going after the h-bond
rook captures and c3 with rook out for
some h2 and now King the b6
cover Blanca delivers check with rook to
be to check King captures on a5 and here
g5 and it was in this position
that last button kappa blanka agreed to
a draw because well they say that there
is no point for either side to push for
something here for if you want we could
play this out to convince you that it is
a draw for example wise could offer up
trade Ruby three chakras captures and
now start pushing on the Kings side
let's say h4 captures captures and now
black will of course try and put a row
behind a passed pawn and start the Queen
this pawn and white will of course get
the King out of the way and try the
Queen this pawn so it's basically erased
but both of them know that there are no
winners in this race so let's say rookie
three defend the pawn but now rook 286
preparing to pull the pawn rook the h3
blocking the pawn and now King e6
now going after this pawn here King to
b6 now preparing to pull the a pond
where King captures on e5 and now a five
here black will use this c5 check to get
to the King a bit away from the a point
with King captures and now kink the f4
I'm going after the rook King back to b5
so you can start pushing your passed
pawn king to G for rook to h1 and now
finally h3 we have a six rope to a trait
and now continuing the race we have pawn
to a7 King to g3 we have king to be 6
and now pawn to h2 teams to b7 now comes
King to g2 and of course here there is
no other way to play this rook captures
at h2 you are trying to make the rope
capture but of course black will capture
with the King King captures now white
will get the Queen inter game rook
captures King captures and there you
have it a nice draw by insufficient
material one of the ways to draw this of
course over there now after g5 both of
them know that this is a raw and the day
don't try to play this out I chose the
this quote above the board I keep on
fighting as long as my opponent can make
a mistake
this is a quote by Manuel Lasker so here
at last for felt that there is no way
come upon who could make a mistake so
you know he didn't think there was even
a possibility that Capablanca makes a
mistake that would allow him to push for
something which is just really insane
how how much per respect cover Blanca
but yeah
now this the game
it's not really a crazy game or anything
but I thought it was really important to
show all the games of the championship
especially since last grace now Donna
points so you know this really shows how
how in what's you know in what condition
he is you know psychologically will he
you know now try to go all out or just
play a normal game and see what happens
here he continues like nothing happened
and this is something you should expect
from from such a strong champion like
Emmanuel Lasker Robert yeah that's it
for Game six I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Edwin and goober
Engelbrecht Coppola Kumar Anthony Brown
Luca petty and cause you call CEO for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
soon you know continuing the cup of
lanka saga the good stuff checking up on
your suggestions and perhaps we'll see
what arises thank you I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
weekend